[Musique]
pendant les périodes écoles tous les
jeunes ont été mis en enseignement à
distance
ça a été possible de le faire pour une
raison assez simple c'est qu'on avait
déjà entamé l'enseignement à distance
avant cette période de confinement liés
aux qu'ovide les jeunes qui étaient en
entreprise eux continuer les entreprises
sauf si les entreprises les ont mis en
chômage partiel
mais même s'ils étaient en chômage
partiel il avait quand même la
possibilité sur les périodes d'école de
suivre l'enseignement à distance à
partir de chez eux
comme on avait du matériel dans l'école
on a prêté du matériel aux jeunes juste
avant la période de confinement
la période j'allais dire de
d'enseignement à distance pendant le
confinement s'est très bien déroulé
c'est à dire qu'on a eu un taux de
décrocheurs qui était au maximum à 5 %
et en fait qui n'est pas supérieur au
nombre de jeunes qui décrochent
lorsqu'on a des cours en présentiel
donc on a maintenu le dispositif
d'enseignement à distance jusqu'à la fin
de l'année scolaire
la seule chose que l'on a fait c'est
qu'on a des étudiants notamment en
master en robotique pour qui il était
impératif de pouvoir terminer leurs
projets sur cette fin d'année pour ces
jeunes
on a mis en place par des petits groupes
de six personnes la possibilité de
réserver la bo de robotique deux jours
par semaine pendant trois semaines et
cela sur la période de fin juin
on a de nouveau sollicité fortement les
entreprises pour recruter des jeunes et
on a mis en place un job dating virtuel
à la place de celui qu'on aurait mis en
présentiel et on mettra cette opération
sur la période du 25 juin au vu de la
réussite de l'enseignement à distance
pendant cette période de confinement
comment on va prolonger de façon à ce
moment-là plus structuré et plus
organisationnel l'enseignement à
distance donc actuellement on est en
train d'étudier ce qu'on appelle les
plans de formation où on revoit la
proportion d'enseignement à distance et
d'enseignement présentiel qui sera mis
en place à partir de la rentrée